[Music]
well you're dressed very nicely in the
past you would come on wearing hockey
jerseys t-shirts but look at you now
you're dressed up like Matlock you you
know it's funny because we roomed
together years ago and I remember
distinctly you walking around the
apartment a lot with no pants on but
underwear yes yes yeah you weren't you
weren't they perfect complete I have an
inability to be where I live with pants
on yeah as soon as I get home I drop the
pants okay so you still to this day like
when you get home from this appearance
you go home I'll have no pants on if I
watch this tonight
if I'm sleeping is the only reason I'm
not gonna watch it by the wise I will
watch you yeah but I'll be in my
underwear
I'm fond of a shirt I always wear shirt
by the way I'm actually at a point now
at my age that I think that I'm more
comfortable being bottomless than
topless right so you like having a shirt
underwear yeah what happens you around
the house okay doorbell rings it's the
guy that once you know install the cable
or whatever and you're there no pants
around you can't stand it's the guy for
the cable yeah I'm in my underwear you
don't put on pants for that guy no not
the guy for the cable okay I get perfect
maybe a queen or something I prepare
it's the Queen of England yes
knocked on your door I would be wearing
pants I'm yes pants okay I'm not even
sweatpants I'd make sure there were
slacks of some sort right something
appropriate now
she's probably outside going he's not
there he's know you love you opening the
door then shutting it back in her face
and running and getting pants on yeah I
know I can see through all right dumbest
conversation dumbest conversation I've
ever had
I've had some dumb conversations you
know not long after living together the
late 80s you had your first big break
was you got to go on Oprah and you were
kind of you were unknown at the time how
did that happen I've never asked you
about that you know you never have I
never you were kind of an unknown
comedian I once I knew you were on Oprah
yes they were doing a show called April
Fool's Day something something all her
producers used to hang out at Zanies in
Chicago and I was nominee yeah and that
was like a house comedian there and they
said would you come through the show and
I said why I have no I don't have any
big problems you know and they said - no
it's this well you're not wearing pants
when they were talking to me I had pants
on okay all right just so we know I
might not by the way there would be a
good Oprah episode men without our pants
yeah
but anyhow I said yes I'll come because
they were really nervous because they
had all these people who'd sent in there
they were telling jokes and then I don't
know any jokes and I went on and just
made up a joke but the key was I said
you don't have a guest do you just of
all these people I say I said I want the
dressing room and I want it filled with
doughnuts and bagels
I used my pole which I didn't have did
they do it yes I went into a room that
was filled with doughnuts and bagels and
I really enjoyed myself amazing that you
knew that Oprah's powerful other people
would want okay I want my own show I
want this and what you want a room
filled with doughnuts and bagels and
that's it at that point in my life when
I was eating tons of sugar I'll eat
sugar anymore I don't eat wheat anymore
a room full of bagels and doughnuts
about as good as it gets maybe a lot but
a LOX platter and some naked ladies be
fantastic
locks bladder and naked ladies yeah very
nice